and on a scale from one to ten what
would you rank yourself seven
nicki minaj gives herself a seven on the
hotness scale just one of many surprise
confessions from the rapper during an
instagram live with image and dating
expert kevin samuels it's not a problem
with men and marriage in relationships
our women are preoccupied with doom
gloom
fear he's known for giving black women
controversial dating advice on social
media nikki invited kevin to go live
after asking fans for dating advice
questions which led to the whole ratings
debate what do you rate me nikki kicks
off the conversation by asking kevin who
once rated rapper sweetie as a six to
rate her on a scale from 1 to 10. is
that what we starting out with
yeah what i typically don't do is i
don't typically rate people i ask they
rate themselves i usually ask this
question well let's start it that way
kevin asks nikki a series of questions
including her dress size i
guess four and what she rates herself
fresh-faced out of the shower
seven
can't use seven
that's why seven is the most common
answer
but the dating expert says nikki's wrong
she's actually a nine you have the
facial symmetry
and you get additional points for eyes
full lips
once that was out of the way nikki got
into other people's business chiming in
on some hot topics she's seen on tick
tock black women can we stop talking
about if black men if these successful
black men want us or not
like can we just focus on us and we be
successful and then we go out there and
we decide who
we want now we all know nikki's out of
the dating game she married her
childhood friend kenneth petty back in
2019. when i was so crazy when i was
little i always imagined you know
princess and marriage and wedding the
wedding and now
it's more to me about
the
the life the future the love the
partnership than the wedding which is so
strange because i didn't expect myself
to be one of those people who didn't
care about the hoopla but i really don't
and he was asking me today too he was
like so you know what when are we going
to do it like cause you keep on you know
i'm like
yeah
i just i just kind of feel like it
doesn't mean as much as as it used to
mean because the other part the real
part i have it now and i'm so happy but
that happens when you're with the right
person thank you yeah
okay the pair is all about sharing their
love with the barbs and their famous
friends they recently spent some time
with another couple fans can't get
enough of rihanna and asap rocky who are
now expecting a baby i couldn't tell you
how happy i am back in september the
caribbean queens linked up for a date
night nikki captioned the post hashtag
caribbean girls run it love her down yes
yankee stadium
[Music]
to rise